white and i'm the chairman of this
committee
members we are hopefully going to stream
this meeting live as well as recording
and by being present in the meeting you
are giving your consent to being
recorded
during each item please put up your hand
to indicate if you wish to speak
and i will then invite you at the
appropriate time
please note that the youtube live stream
sound recording is dependent on the
correct use of the microphones therefore
can i ask that when invited to speak you
remember to turn on your microphone and
turn it off when finished
please reference a page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers and keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible
and we'll now move on to a gender item
two which is apologies for absence um do
we have any burner hazel tara i think
it's burner
okay the only the only apologies i have
is councillor penny channel who has been
delayed and hopes to attend later
um agenda item three is the minutes on
the meeting held on the third of
february 2022 found on pages 15 to 18
are approved as a true and accurate
record i so move do i have a seconder
agreed by sent yep thank you uh
okay um this councilor fluke was got him
just first
and so agreed by a cent
um
uh gender item number four declarations
of interest do we have any uh counselor
darren
yeah chairman a non-binary interest
should there be anything on the agenda
um as a member of etsu's county council
thank you thank you and council stamp
uh thank you madam chair just that i'm a
member of essex county council uh a
non-pecuniary interest if anything comes
up i can't say anything modern chair
i'll let you know thank you
nope okay now we move on to agendum item
five
which is public participation and there
is none
so we'll move on to agenda item six and
this is a notice of motion to consider
the following motion which has been
referred to this committee by the
council in accordance with notice julie
given under procedural four councillor
fluker to move the following motion
julie seconded by councillor duik and
councillor helm
motion two preamble with regards to the
planning cost decisions awards against
the council reference appeal numbers i'd
like you to read those out for the
miserable years 22 22 23 24 and 24 25
the council is forecasting significant
shortfalls in its budgets the cost
decisions referred to above and others
along with legal and professional fees
incurred by the council when defending
appeals will substantially increase
unaccounted expenditure and therefore
widen the budget gaps further as a
result of these additional costs the
council will need to draw down and use
its cash reserves public funds to enable
it to continue to provide services to
residents
the motion to council with regards to
fiscal proprietary public interest and
value to customers the director of
resources in his role under section 151
local government act 1972 brings forward
an autumn budget for consideration by
council
do i have any questions
counselor fluker
microphone as well i thought i had the
opportunity to speak with you indeed
because obviously it's not being dealt
with black house so we can of course
debate this but before i do chairman um
can i can i extend my congratulations to
you on your elevation to the chairman of
this committee
i know i know you well from
chairing other committees and i know
that you're very keen to get the
business done properly quickly and with
all integrity so i'll be quick um
chairman i think it's important for all
of us to to recognize the extraordinary
financial pressures the council is under
even though we received substantial
grants from the government
we've still had to bear costs and loss
of income because of the pandemic
however
additional extraordinary costs have now
been incurred outside of the current
budget envelope are more likely to
follow
as we all know inflation is running at
its highest level for 20 plus years and
energy and fuel costs are set to
increase substantially over the next six
months
specific unbudgeted costs for example
for example costs award
against the council and its own costs in
relation to planning bills are currently
running at more than 250 000 pounds a
quarter of a million pound that is money
public money that's going to have to be
taken out of the reserves to satisfy the
cost appeal decision
the proposed overhaul that the planning
service is also likely to have massive
cost implications on the council and i
look forward to seeing the director of
service deliveries report in due course
um
and this evening chairman we'll we're
also considering even more unbudgeted
costs um i mean i've looked through the
agenda tonight and you can you can pick
them up all of this taren is against a
backdrop of the council forecasting
unprecedented budget deficits in the
coming years i mean it
you know it is frightening where this
council is is currently going i mean mr
leslie brought forward a brilliant
report to to council at the budget
meeting and he certainly didn't shy away
from explaining what the situation
really is
um with the figures involved in the
likely massive impact on our cash
reserves the council in my mind must act
now to protect its cash assets
not only for the benefit of residents
and taxpayers but also for us to enable
the bringing forward of income
generating corporate projects now german
i know
most of those are discussed under the
cover of confidentiality but members
that are involved will understand what
some of those costs are
all of these projects are
loaded up front we'll need a huge amount
of money to prime them before we even
get close to receiving any income back
um
with the figures in
in the past year
we have relied on underspends to balance
our accounts but given the fiscal
position of the council and the pressure
it faces
this sort of uh i'm sure mr leslie's
heard me use this expression this sort
of hope accountancy no longer has a
place
because even with an underspender i
believe it's going to get used up anyway
acting now chairman will ensure the new
administration beginning in may
2023 is given the best chance of
succeeding
and chairman we we owe it to the next
administration
ensure that we leave them in a strong
position
it's we've all heard that thing where
the government changed and there was a
piece of paper left in the treasury
there's no money left i'm not saying
there won't be any money left in may but
we need to give them the best possible
opportunity and i know that some of you
here tonight
may be part of the council in 11 months
time and i think it's important chairman
that we do that
um
as far as residents and taxpayers are
concerned tonight's vote
is really about if not
why not
because i think
every household in the district is
looking at their personal budgets at the
moment to see how they're going to break
even how they're going to put food on
the table at the end of the month how
they're going to pay their bills
that said chairman i hope the committee
members will recognize the benefit
of not dealing with additional costs on
a piecemeal basis and that they support
my motion that the 151 officer brings
together
both the cost
pressures and the predicted additional
costs in one document
and presents that as an autumn budget
to do otherwise chairman would be remiss
of us as the custodians of public funds
and we mustn't lose sight of the fact
that we are the custodians of this money
on behalf of the residents and
businesses of this
district
um chairman the motion is in the agenda
i know um i know that everybody's read
it you've put it so i propose german
that i move my motion thank you
do i have a second of that um
thank you councilman uh right now i'd
like to open the floor to the debate
please and i have counselor sidle who'd
like to speak first and then councillor
uh thank you chair
um i'd just like to ask chris
uh mr leslie sorry uh
could you tell us at the moment
whether the reserves are the highest
they've been for the council in the past
few years that's my first question
christmas leslie yeah thank you yes i
believe the reserves are the highest
day's been for for a number of years
currently okay um so that their reserves
are the highest they've ever been
so i understand
well i think it is ever isn't it they're
the highest they've ever been
looking back from recent years yes i've
only gone back so far but i think it's
probably a safer something to say that's
going to be higher than
mr leslie um so yeah over the past few
years
one of the things that i think mr leslie
has done is to ensure that our
accounting is correct and accurate it's
not piecemeal and i find that word very
insulting to the officers of the council
in terms of it being a piecemeal and
that we're doing things as we go along
one of the things that we've really
tried to do over the past few years
yeah on both from both sides of the the
chamber is to ensure that the finance
working group reviews the finances as we
go along that is already happening it
happened last year where we reviewed the
finances in june last year to look at
where we were and what we needed to do
and at that particular point we decided
to
recruits some officers because we felt
that we could afford to
so in terms of the current situation yes
we do need to be careful about how we
spend money and the way that we spend
money but the council is in a secure
position
and one of the things that we need to
really do
is to ensure
that we get the balance right and we are
still able to deliver the services
to our residents and that's one of the
most important things that we we've got
to do
is we have to ensure that we deliver the
services and that we at the same time
we
maintain our budget and we maintain our
fans and that's what i believe the
council is already doing so i feel that
a secondary budget
will just tie up officers time when they
could be concentrating on other things
thank you thank you council little and
now i'll go to councillor lagoon thank
you chair i think um
council should have said an awful lot so
i can call mine right down i think that
the of what i understand the intent of
the the motion i think that council
cereal said about the time is going to
take the diversion of resources away
and from other needy projects uh work
that needs to be done uh
really is not currently needed i mean as
mr leslie says when he presents the
budgets to non-financial people like
myself they're pretty easy to understand
they're an assumed budget and no one can
know exactly every penny and this cost
pressure was unforeseen uh was came out
of a decision by council and that
decision was made by council and and the
consequences were there and i'm sure
there'll be other decisions that happen
in the future and members know i'm not
keen on every single project that we we
look at from a commercial perspective
but i want to protect what we've got
while we've got it
with regard to officers time so i think
it's i concur with councillor siddal and
that this is probably not necessarily
needed at this moment in time
thank you councillor again um councillor
darren
yeah thank you chairman
um
a couple of points and then and then a
question for the officers
um
yeah i i take on board that we've got
good um good reserves but reserves were
there for you know rainy days
um and it's important that they are
maintained i think we have to accept
that we are in
extraordinary times
um
we are seeing the cost of living we are
seeing cost pressures
the residents are seeing cost pressures
and
we have to be mindful that um
the prediction is for unemployment rates
to increase
there will be more people on universal
credit probably next year and our
council tax collection rates are
predicted to
to come under some pressure
but um so yes it's absolutely essential
that we keep a very close eye
and we're not in a normal situation
because we do have these extraordinary
costs the cost award against us which
we're not fully okay with that and that
could be
a significant chunk out of our budget
that's the statement my question is
how practical is it for the officers to
prepare a full budget
as against
maintaining normal fiscal probity and
keeping
a good
a good
analysis of the accounts that could be
reported back to council
more frequently than actually just
waiting for a an autumn budget it's
absolutely essential that we keep
a very very close eye on on this but i'm
not a hundred percent sure
that the um the work that would go into
producing a full budget
is going to achieve anything more than
uh
an ongoing analysis of the costs and the
uh and we need to maintain a good
view of our potential future liabilities
it's lizzie
i think it might be helpful for me to
talk about what's currently in place our
existing budget framework
perhaps to answer that question i think
firstly there's the budget monitoring
process
that we have which throughout the year
we provide updates on our assumptions
such as inflation pay awards and funding
things like that we look at that budget
performance and budget challenges such
as contract renewals that may come in so
there's a constant budget monitoring
process which goes on
and this provides updated forecasts and
the last uh at the last member meeting i
believe we started to show some
forecasts as well
there as well so that happens throughout
the year to give those updates anyway
there's also the budget setting process
uh which takes place and part of that of
the proposals are being developed to
improve the financial position
and these were shown as well at the all
member briefing um after going through
appropriate governments
uh including actually the finance
working group uh these will come forward
to members in around the uh the autumn
time along with all the fees and charges
policies and traditions so that those
things will be coming forward
to members
of options to address the the budget gap
and of course updated forecasts anyway
as part of the budget monitoring and
partners budgets set in process of
course at that time there'd be
information we won't have
we don't have for example the local
government finance settlement won't be
available that time which we do come the
february time as well and of course
assumptions will further change between
autumn and that february time um
as well in terms of actually the the
detailed of a budget report obviously we
do a lot of uh detailed levels in terms
of the low-level accounts and we produce
various reports etcetera for that um i
wouldn't have thought that would be
necessarily what would be required or be
enough might be might be wrong but that
side of it is quite labor intensive and
certainly what we do anyway is produce
those uh assumptions they're monitoring
and also come forward with those
proposals for members as well as part of
the existing processes
yep so just to conclude thank you mr
leslie so
so you are confident that
through the existing procedures that we
are keeping a close eye
on the financial situation
taking on board the potential
risks and liabilities waste contract
leisure contract future appeal costs etc
etc
and have the ability to report back to
members the fiscal situation at any
given time
yeah absolutely that's the purpose of
the budget monitoring reports that's why
we come forward
and we wouldn't do anything really that
different from a budget setting to what
we currently do in terms of the
monitoring side of it we absolutely
report the monitoring to members and we
do that through the finance working
group as well as the committee sections
uh councillor thompson
thank you chairman um i'm grateful to
councillor durham for his question
because that's
saved everybody a lot of time listening
to me um i do actually recall
the reserves being and you probably do
too being more like 12 million at some
point i've only written the recent past
what we joined because it came from a
you know a massive sale of property that
we've unfortunately
had a long long time it is a long long
time ago but it was a huge reserve that
came
almost a windfall that we've never
managed to build up any other way so
you know in the great scheme of things
they're lower than they have been
but
i do think it's mainly the job of the
working group and this
committee to look at the monitoring i
think the monitoring has been done at
least as well as it's ever been very
possibly better so thank you mr leslie
um i
i can see that it would be very labor
intensive to produce a full budget we've
managed to take on some extra staff for
the accounting
department but that's because we needed
it we don't have extra resource there
just to
give them things to do
so you know should it become necessary
then yes but at the moment i can't
support it i think we should carry on as
we are the working group worked hard
this committee works hard
leaders well on top of this assisted by
me when i can
um so now i'm not i don't feel able to
support this at the moment thank you
okay thank you um councillor
yeah thank you madam chair um i'm
totally in agreement with actually
councillor siddall um the finance
working group i can't remember if i'm on
it i don't think i am this time but when
i was on it i think council siddal was
the chairman
and i think it was very well run the
questions were posed that there was
tight and new
procedures introduced um
mr leslie always answered the questions
and we were quite grilling when we was
asking him questions i mean i can
remember capsule sidle and i had a
massive disagreement because i wanted to
to increase some staff and he wouldn't
let me do it when he was chair of snl
and i think we're going to be in that
same position because we have to be
realistic even now things are going to
come to this committee because it was
stripped bare under the transformation
there isn't the meat on the bones and
councillor stills right we have to we're
going to have to make decisions on what
services we're going to provide and what
we can't provide madam chair because we
can't afford it but we can't keep
putting stress and pressures what
members feel should be put on members of
staff who are still on their recovery
from the burnout from covid and all the
pressures that have been put on them and
i think while i totally agree in some
degree to councillor fluke what he said
and i think it would be prudent i don't
think it's necessary at the time and i'm
sorry but i i won't be supporting that
motion thank you madam chair
thank you is uh councillor swain and
then councillor fluker come back oh yes
thank you man
and i think if the reserves were as high
as 12 million it was probably some
intra-year um coincidence of influx of
funds however to get to
speak on the motion
um
i i think uh council of fuku is rather
manufacturing um an issue here and
inflating it and
trying to use what is a
an event operationally and turn it into
a financial
issue
and at the same time um the with the
language is used here uh
perhaps giving the public an impression
that we're in an emergency situation but
when
we do need to look at the whole issue of
costs awards
appeals and i think the general
performance of
appeals and
overturned decisions going on but that's
not really relevant to this particular
issue of the
proposed budget
what we have is one of the events that
crop up during the
year and the reference to unaccounted at
least to
the public eye might imply that mr
leslie has been remiss in some way which
of course he hasn't
and this is um just one of those things
the sort of thing that crops up during
the year and has come to fluke a
referral we've got one coming up later
on on the agenda
um
introducing the medium
financial position whether you call it
statement or whatever um i think is uh
rather a red herring it's it's um
too much a tangent to the the issue of
the
costs and any short-term budget um i
think the
the graph which mr leslie produces
showing um reserves
uh in nose dive is
not a four cops it's just a projection
based on limited knowledge
a few things that we do know and
can forecast reasonably and substantial
unknowns plus and plus and minus um
and
i would say that the third year of the
ntfs never arrives
because um it is always we're always
looking at over the next year or two and
uh things will look very different for
that year and for the year or two
afterwards and as council [ __ ] knows
that there are all sorts of things which
could um add to our reserves
where i
would agree with him is that there is a
overall a structural problem
with our finances
in that
on all the
views
um the rate of inflation is going to
affect our
expenditure much more severely than our
income
and that is uh something which would
have to be looked at
and we would have to be very judicious
about any use of capital receipts to
to fill that gap
um but that is for the long term i i
can't see any um reason
for um taking emergency measures and
instituting uh what would effectively be
an emergency budget
thank you thank you councillor swain and
councillor fluker
i'll take the right to sum up um but i
want to make sure everyone's
coming yeah okay
so um look as far as checks and
challenges are concerned i agree yeah
that we've actually got a pretty robust
system but checks and challenges may
just actually show up a massive deficit
now as far as manufacturing
reasons i i i would say this chairman mr
leslie
whose praises have been sung of high in
the last half an hour
is predicting a uh a million pound uh
loss in three years time
uh a lot of money
uh as for the reserves chairman
um i think we've actually only got six
million pound in the revenue account and
as councillor thompson says there was
there was a time when we had over 20
million in in our general fund
um which over the years has just been
eroded and eroded away and let's not
forget that in the reserves is the new
homes bonus
and the new homes bonus isn't there to
prop up this council
it might be paying for the local the
review of the local development plan
which is a million plus quid i
understand
it can be used for that but wouldn't it
be brilliant if we could use the new
homes bonus chairman to provide for the
residents of this district particularly
those
around some of these large developments
you know we shouldn't be relying upon
that to prop up the council and chairman
maybe
i believe that the word piecemeal was
correct but perhaps
perhaps i used it in the wrong context
or within the wrong sentence but what i
was saying was is that we seem to be
bringing forward a lot of you know small
pockets costs and big pockets of cost
you know we've got
some small and big pockets of costs
tonight to consider none of these are
budgeted
i know mr holmes is bringing forward a a
a plan to
pga
and that's going to have cost
implications as well but none of these
costs are wrapped up into anything so
i'm expecting chairman that having
pretty much worked out the will of this
committee
when we get to reports chairman when i
turn to the back of it and it says
impact on financial resources i would
expect mr leslie to say that this is not
budgeted and this is going to come out
the bottom line so and as far as
you know producing a set of flash
accounts and that's what we'd be doing
in the autumn i'm not asking for
statutory budget i'm asking for
for an autumn budget or an autumn budget
statement
to really show where we are
and i think that's very very important i
know that all these things are being
reported to various places but not
everybody is in various places and a lot
of people on full council i think are
very concerned about about the budget
um
so and the other thing that concerned me
enormously earlier on was mr leslie
mentioned
he actually mentioned
the budget gap
and reviewing the budget gap as we went
on
now
great if it's if it's in a negative but
if it's in a positive and it has to be
in a quarter of a million pound positive
either the carry forward from last year
is down a quarter of a million or this
year's down a quarter million you know
it's got to be one or the other
so i'm i'm just a little bit concerned
about that
um
but chairman i'll i'll um i'll put the
motion and and and can i say it's been
wonderful to give everybody off the
opportunity
uh to hear my points i know that the
media are interested in this and i know
that today i've been contacted by quite
a few
um members of the public because they
are concerned about the budget so we've
done it i think it's been a very full
and um and
deep debate and i think everybody will
be grateful for that so thank you very
much i'll put my motion chairman uh
i get the last word chairman so i'll put
my emotion
and that's it thank you no that's the
wall
ah
yeah well we certainly don't want to be
using rule 32 every time we but i mean
i'll read the constitution
actually it can't i will indulge council
legend to
ask this question it's more of an
observation than a question and it's not
actually a criticism so uh i hope you
can hear that um but you just said
something counselor focused on something
really impactful about the money we're
spending on the ldp it just figures into
my head that maybe we should then have a
look at what we're actually doing within
that process which is something to throw
out to members at this point in time
thank you thank you councillor would you
like to be on motion again please
um
um
would you would like to show um
how you vote on this whether you agree
with
do we have a seconder for a recorded
vote
nobody
in this community is going to say
so
i've done the last section but cheering
in the bars that would be
all right
okay so all of those in in favor of the
motion could you please show
all of those against
any abstentions
thank you say that and i didn't quite
see them but i think that was everybody
voted against the motion apart from me
no counsellor
and i think that's important to to note
that chairman thank you
thank you councillor fluker
okay
if we can move on to the next agenda
item which is a gender item seven which
is the supplementary estimates
environments procurement exemptions and
use of river reserves from the first of
january to the 31st of march 2022
welcome councillor chana and mr leslie
if i can
you did you did um thank you and mr
leslie if you'd like to
present this one
thank you
okay this is a regular item where the
financial regulations require that these
are reported when they occur
this time there are only procurement
exemptions to be reported
exemptions are reported in this way to
provide transparency around why the
exemption was necessary rather than
being to explain why the expenditure
occurred
the majority of these exemptions were
once funded by the additional
restrictions grant where expenditure was
time restricted and work was undertaken
with partners to deliver a package of
support for the local businesses
to debate
anybody any questions on this
okay recommendation then okay moving on
to
agendata item eight which is the malden
district gateway signage and i think
we've got jack presenting this one
there are
highway signs as you approach the
district from the various roads
um
some changes to regulations meant that
different signs can be
created and members are probably aware
of the chance for sites as you approach
challenges which show highlands house
under the
surf program
we funded a scheme of design to create
these signs
and this report is about the approval of
those as concepts
included in the document in the report
is the illustration of those signs which
include a sig which
was produced
but it proposed that it would pursue
better to be
a town site as you enter my graduation
because that's something you would have
to look into
before the benefit of everyone presents
i'm able to share these signs
see my screen
yes we can
this is a sign uh one science movie
message towards southern districts
celebrating the vineyards crouch as well
as some of the heritage uh assets of the
district
outside showing uh the largest district
claims for
the statute of britain with the backup
of the town and high key
and almost a reverse of that throwing
the high street down to the river
the toll spree light ship uh tells me
marshes
it's easy to see there is perhaps
[Music]
thank you and we have a recommendation
um to
approve the signs do i have before we we
take a uh a second do we have a second
for that
yep okay and now open the floor to
debate councillor darren
i just want to say they're excellent i
think they're really really well done
thank you very much indeed
and i think they put the ridiculous
chunks of ones to shame so well done
i agree entirely um i've got counselor
stamp next
thank you chair um
madam chair i've heard you changed your
name already
um i'm afraid i actually don't agree um
sorry um and i'd like to ask has any
consultation been given before coming to
this committee to speaking to town and
parish councils about this project and
the reason i'm saying that is because i
know of at least one council who's
already
agreed a budget to replace their town
signage and it looks nothing like this i
think different parishes and towns are
renowned for different heritage and and
i certainly i i agree the clock tower is
is brilliant for for burnham on crouch
totally it's iconic
but
i i'm really disappointed that no
consultation has taken place i presume
has not taken place because it certainly
hasn't come to burnham on crouchdown
council about this and then discussed it
with in case they had any previous plans
about any prospective new signage that
they'd already agreed because it's my
understanding we don't have to have
approval from this district or this
committee to have our own time sounds it
goes to essex county council
thank you madam chair and i'm sorry i
think some of them are fine but not not
and i know you're going to say it's
standard and we all should do it but i
don't want to be standard we're
individual thank you mr allen
yes thank you chair thanks for the
question
for clarity these are the ones i've
shown
are the district sites so they're the
entry points to the district um town
signage is different for instance to be
aware that the malden town signs were
replaced fairly recently
and there is
this report is not asking for commitment
to the burn or crouch outside which of
course
should be a matter for consideration of
birmingham council
the science um have been developed uh to
try and represent the various assets and
the wording being used you'll see has a
slight variation
um that's about the limits of variation
we're allowed by highways
they're not keen on having vastly
different signs as you went to the um
into the district but yeah just for
clarity this is
not town signage village signage as you
approach a village town this is district
signage as you've joined
the
district uh other signage announcing
your arrival to the towns such as exists
for malden it can be done uh it's a
separate matter thanks to yes all
signage requires you to
okay thanks chad i will allow you to
come back thank you madam chair so where
will it go
if you're not going to put a burnham on
crouchdown sign in orthon are you so so
if if you you know but no no sorry am i
being heckled
um so so now i don't understand it and
also yeah maybe i am being dense but
you know um
i'm speaking not as a town councillor
because it hasn't come to the town
council this is my personal view so i
want to make that clear but where would
it go then
if it's is it going to go next to the
burnham crouch town sign no it's for
debate tonight
yes
is
because it was one of the
short lists of uh options that was
developed that piece of artwork showing
the cloth tower so rather than waiting
for the
commission's
agency that undertook the design and i
felt to include this to show what else
is possible in terms of town signage and
for clarity on where they go
there's uh admittedly absolutely
included further detail but there's the
listed road numbers within the report
and their approximate location and these
would go on the boundary of the district
of this boundary
there is currently a sign of some type
in those locations
the majority some have been replaced
very recently with very small
short-term replacements but the majority
are actually a very poor standard
condition
okay thank you mr mike counselor yeah
yeah thanks thanks for the point of
clarity as well because i think that's
sort of throwing us thrown us all um
first of all tim can i just pay tribute
to to the the people that provided the
artwork and it's not lost on me chairman
that the sailing barge
reminder appears in one of these and i
hope councillor lagos picked up on that
um but chairman this is this is
corporate branding this is this is um
you know district-wide branding i think
anybody that drives around the district
and goes in and out as i do you'll see
some of these signs some of them are in
an appalling state i like the palette
i'm not sure if i buy into the uh some
of the strat lines but you know that's
the marketing thing um i i think it
would be nice german that cometh the
time
if
parish and town councils were given the
opportunity to buy into this scheme at
their cost i think that would be good
because i think south minster certainly
would you know would like a new sign
and my other
point is uh chairman is um
mr ellen mentioned uh the agency fees
so bearing in mind under implications it
says none uh a bit upon resources
financial none no funding is being
requested at this time now gentlemen you
know i don't want to go on about this
but i suspect these signs are probably
going to cost five grand a pop by the
way by the time they're installed
they're going to be five thousand pound
each by the time somebody comes along
digs a hole puts them up and everything
else so we've got about 25 grand here i
don't doubt chairman that the members
will take that money out of reserves or
some other pot to do this if they have
the will to do it but it would be useful
i think chairman under impacts on
resources what the likely costs of these
bless shoe council in china um you know
what what the impact is on resources and
we should know early if it's 25 grand i
don't think anybody would welch on that
it's got to come out of some budget
somewhere
but you know if it's 50 000 then i think
people might say well let's put it back
to
another year
so but i think generally i think um
chairman i would support this and and i
do like the palette to be honest so i
hope you picked up on that i do like the
color palette thank you mr lizzie could
you oh and chairman just one thing
uh for mr ellen one thing you know you
know we've picked out some of our big
iconic uh points you know in the
district but i really do think that you
know whether we like it or not we should
refer to renewable energies because we
have a lot of wind farms in this
district we've got a lot of solar arrays
coming through in the next few months
and i think that you know we should say
something you know even if we just got a
little wind mill
you know on uh in the background
somewhere i just think that'd be good is
it yeah
mr ellen could you just confirm the
total cost for us please
yes
um
uh
okay thank you mr lam right councillor
chana next
thank you thank you madam chairman um
just to say i think these illustrate
actually uh what the district is about
it's about our salt marsh coast our
history um and our culture
like council of luca i like the palette
and i think actually
uh the designs for each entry point to
the district exemplify it well like you
know on the b1012s from southwestern
paris all along there that main road
well wonder what a word strategic route
or whatever um you've got all the
vineyards and hence why we've got the
the grapes the purple grapes there and
the other elements
indeed and to do with them stoma is
we've got the plain and everything and
then likewise coming in from danbury
we've got the barges
and from hatfield pebble and then also
coming in from salt cup we've seen um
the lovely um
vettel vessel there's at toll spring
where i've been on many courses actually
the old lighthouse as i called a [ __ ]
called that
so i actually think it's a very good
exercise that's been carried out um the
officers explained about the funding and
i think actually um they are a branding
they are what the ca um the district's
about and they get a very um good
message over the work the pictures
actually speak as well as the words
often with signage you get words that
don't actually top with the
illustrations but i think the whole
package here really does proclaim what
the malden district council is about
thank you councilman um councillor
thompson i think he's next
thank you chairman um yes i agree with
councillor durham he's not chelsea's
into a cult hat so thank you very much
jack and the
team um i i think the burnham one is a
bit confusing because it it
does seem
fairly obvious that the rest are going
to be at the margins of the district so
i'm a bit unclear about why there's a
burning one and why wouldn't there be a
more than one hey which won't be
yes um i think yeah and any others that
aren't on the margins should you know as
it happens we're lucky that we don't
have any towns that are on the edge of
the district so that's the problem that
doesn't arise um i have a very slight
query over the tollsbury one it's it
makes a change from sail lofts
big plus
i'm not sure is it a problem that the
light ship actually belongs to a
religious organization i don't know if
i'm creating problems where nobody had
any but i wouldn't like that to come up
as an issue later
and
i don't know maybe it would make them
cluttered and maybe it was a conscious
decision but there's no sense of place
icons on it um
there might be a reason for it if there
is a reason perhaps through you chairman
mr allen could give us an answer mr
ellen
yes happy to uh
uh
the live show
very visible um
very viewable thing and there's a path
right next to it so i think it's one of
the more striking images
that we chose to pursue um
there's two reasons uh for the absence
of the graphic language or
color palette one is that that would be
used as a logo and uh
um
wouldn't be tolerated by highway signage
so it'd be very comfortable to be able
to show
multiple elements they're very if
they're happy with a picture and the
wording but once you complicate that up
and the other thing to say is these are
sensitive ways around it's the color
palette is the sense of place color
habits
so it's it's utilizing that but perhaps
in a more subtle more understandable
more interesting way
hence that
okay thanks thank you very much thanks
very much chairman yes i'm sorry i
didn't grasp the palette i evidently do
don't do subtle at any rate not with
graphic design
um but thank you i did think it would be
better to raise the you know the
ownership of the light ship now rather
than later but i think it's a lovely
design and looking at the
the one of the vineyards um i think
they're
geese and the power station rather than
windmills
i didn't think it was that big but
anyway thank you um i appreciate your
answers
newton i um
that we're showing in that picture
we did at one point have uh windmills on
that picture but from that vista there
are no windmills uh
turbines to the south of the river and
it's of course the view looking from the
north towards the south
thank you
thank you uh councillor lagan
thanks chair um
members and officers in this chamber
know how passionate i am and nobody
probably know officers more than mr
butcher and mr holmes know what pain in
the backside i can be um but it's all
done with the right intention um
when i saw these there's two things that
came to mind i thought they really do
brand it i think they're absolutely
superb um and they as councillor dharam
says and they do not chance with marconi
off the spot for six it's about pride in
the district and seeing this certainly
does give me that and the second feeling
was the irony of the whole thing because
a couple of years ago we sat in this
chamber and certain members were saying
about if the barges went and something
else will come
and it's just lovely to see the the
barges um yeah i think it's true and the
barge is represented so well
on so many
signage because they are more than the
key which must be protected is malden um
so this really sends out a statement and
i sincerely would have loved the
reminder to have been on the the the
sign there uh councillor fluger but
unfortunately it probably strikes me as
the dawn because the coloration is
different and reminded we didn't run
with a bowsprit but i appreciate you
thinking of my old barge because i hold
her with great affection
no no she's a different color no this i
think the and jack you've done a
sterling job and thank you
thank you councillor
i i've got no idea what what part it is
so i think we'll just leave that one
there and right moving forward
councillor siddal next
thank you chair yeah so uh the
working group the covered reset working
group spent a lot of time and we've
consulted really well with the designers
um in terms of coming up with these
images and and there is an iterative
process
in terms of them being at every entry
point they're not at every entry point
so one of the one of the things to
remember is they're not at every inch
point they're at the main entry points
to the district so for example on blue
mills hill there is not going to be one
there in great baxter there's not going
to be one there so it's the main key
points so they're not going to every
single thing so therefore it's not about
representing towns and parishes it's
about representing the district the
reason why the burnham time was produced
because the designers came up with lots
of different things and that one was
developed a little bit further than some
of the other so that's why it was
presented to the committee
there was also one of saint peter's on
the wall which wasn't as formed and
that's probably why it's not appeared
these to me are iconic they are very
similar than what we went for is going
back to the idea of the the railway
posters and things like that so trying
to create those sorts of images
and you can see these being sold on
postcards
and being created as postcards because
they are such an iconic
representation of the district and i
think it will really enhance and really
be of a benefit to the district in terms
of saying this is malden and that's the
crucial thing these signs are all about
saying this is malden or the malden
district
thank you i've got councillor durham
next
yeah thank you i think we're just
getting a bit carried away on this uh a
councillor siddall has stolen my thunder
so he says nothing to do with parishes
and as he said this is on the main
routes into the district from other
districts from chelmsford or from
colchester or whatever i'm in wooden
walter which is also a border village
there isn't going to be one on spring
elms lane or bassets lane where there is
actually a sign saying you're entering
malden district
so you know for goodness sake and we
don't need the burning one very nice
very nice picture of burnham if burnham
want to put one there they can pay us
and have it but this is on the key
element the key entry routes from
another district into the malden
district not malden town
not south minster not burnham
malden district from another district
and absolutely that's how they should be
and they are iconic in images and
there's nothing more to be said we're
just overthinking it okay
so we've got the recommendation uh
we're happy to oh sorry councillor swain
i must apologize can we just come in
very late with one
i agree that the question of the town
signs for burnham is should be left as a
separate issue
um
two points on the signs uh one is about
the size of them
mr ellington can say and uh despite what
was just being said about the key points
of entry to the district
um is this
is one
there's one suffice um in the south
wooden paris area
um as i suppose that the um road in
northwoods the district is
um just as uh key as the one going east
to burnham
or does one sign suffice to do that
i have to say i can i can speak on the
entry into um from from um wooden
fairies that actually goes into my ward
and that is the main route in to the
south um but if i can move to mr ellen
and that's defined by the available
verge
that's there
roughly talking with thinking about the
size of the chelmsford signs probably as
a maximum
and as i said depends on a number of
things but particularly the size of the
first distance away from the growth
itself that you can place the sign
the speed of the road and a few other
things but i think it's worth
considering that we would be looking to
do roughly the size of chapter size
as to these smaller rows many of them
don't have the available verge size that
could save some hole
big enough
of course you need to have them as a
suitable life and
them at 40 miles an hour and if you've
only got a very narrow purge between
that private property you simply don't
have capacity to do it
but the intention did look at other
options but these were identified as the
five major routes into the district
okay uh so we'll be going i'm happy to
agree the recommendation by ascent
agreed
okay you're welcome okay moving on thank
you um jack moving on to
agenda item nine
which is the uk shared prosperity and
leveling up funding opportunities um
which is um i think it's leander cable
who's presenting this one
thank you chair and good evening members
uh the report has been designed to
provide an update on the opportunity
reception by the government's uk sheriff
sorority fund and the leveling up plans
firstly the uk share prosperity part is
part of the government's leveling up
gender which provide 2.6 billion pounds
worth of key folding
the funding indications were released
13th
2022 and this confirmed that morgan
district council had been allocated one
million pounds to be served by march
2025.
the fund is a mix of revenue for the
capital which competes for delivering a
wide range of interventions
these can be you can complement but not
duplicate large-scale projects funded
through the leveling upgrades community
real advanced and clean entrepreneurship
fund
the funding will be tapered starting
this financial year 2022 2023
and close in 2020 to 2024 2025 and
there's three investment objectives they
are community in place supporting open
business or people in skills
people and skills element will come in
the third year for folding
the allocations in
three years totally a million pounds for
the first year it's fifty nine thousand
and nineteen pounds
second year is 180 pounds
for a thousand pounds 38 and in the
latter year receipt the majority of the
money is
nine hundred 822
forty two pounds
morgan district council as a legal open
authority will be responsible for
developing and submitting our investment
plan between
june and the first of august this year
twenty
for us thousand pounds
initial preparatory work for the fund
including developing the investment plan
this 20 000 times addition to the
allocation we will receive will only be
paid back once our investment plan has
been signed off
meaning that we'll need to recover the
initial expenditure
a further report will be brought to
future committee outlander posts to
marriage
and monitor the fund
the leveling up fund will focus on
investment projects that perhaps 23
pounds worth of funding there is no
minimum bid level
round one was opened in march 2021 and
305 bids were received by government
including one from local district
council which is in relation to the
design concentric costs for standard
relief whilst this feed was unsuccessful
the feedback received was useful to
provide provided to perform any future
bids on this scheme or others
round two of the limit voltage announced
in the 2022 spring statements that it
focuses on capital investment in
infrastructure
it's really important to know that
morgan district council was moved from
catchup g2 in the index of priority
places to the higher priority
practically one
the government has confirmed that this
is when the exceptional changes index
round two and as a result one or more of
the following as we've got one more of
the following updated data sets uh used
for two-year averages with some data but
take into account coverage and impacts
and in some parts of the country
accountable government reorganization
the lending up program two funds will
fund projects up to the end of 2024 2025
and has the same three investment themes
as round one transport regeneration of
town centres culture
advocates to this farm will submit their
full bids
with supporting documentation by midday
wednesday 6th of july and future rounds
have not been confirmed
in order to support the preparation of
sufficient high quality bids
and as a new
priority category one area removing
jesuit council will receive 125 000
pounds of capacity funding officers met
with civil servants
representing
the department of dental homes
communities and the department of
business energy and industrial strategy
we made it clear that any post receiving
capacity
would be expected to submit a bid
work is now underway to determine the
most appropriate way to resource the
capacity funding up to the required
remix standard the submission of a bid
will be based on delivering cultural
elements the central area master uh both
waterfront finally at high primarily at
high key
options of course also being considered
and reviewed for birmingham parish
taking into account the local needs the
importance for maritime heritage area
and the assets already in place
thank you chair
thank you and this report is for noting
but i'm happy to open up the floor for
any debate so anybody would like to
raise anything um councillor siddal
uh yeah thank you chair uh yeah this
again shows how invaluable some of our
new officers are to this council in
terms of being able to put some of these
bids together
unfortunately
we don't have enough resources in this
area
and that's one of the problems from the
transformation three years ago again
this council is lacking in resources
due to those cuts
in terms of business and in terms of
working with our community and it's only
leander who's been here since last year
that has been enabling us to get some of
these grants
we need to ensure
that
resources like this
are maintained in this council so we are
able to put these grants put these bids
together
because we are on such
a short time scale
thank you
uh thank you uh councillor thompson
okay a counsellor i'm councillors i've
got councillors stamp council channel
then councillor swain thank you madam
chair um i don't know if leander can
help um or anybody else how are we
actually looking or have we got the
money to look at supporting maybe essex
on this did you go stuff
because you've got we're on about
transport and especially the rural areas
where i am and i'm south it's even more
remote than where i am
but you know some think we we need more
green transport is that what this is
what we're looking at could we apply for
anything like that or is it is that too
big a task that we as a district council
cannot even attempt to tackle and i am
before you um respond leander um
um agree with councillor siddal actually
and you have been worth your weight in
gold and if it isn't for if it wasn't
for certain people coming in and we we
didn't have external funding none of
this would change and we wouldn't change
and we wouldn't grow organically we
would just sit there and fester so i
agree
twice in one night councillor siddal i'm
sure it won't happen again
but no thank you very much thank you
chair
okay thank you uh councillor janna
oh she denied sorry sorry
yeah i got carried away with the praise
and forgot you asked the question
that's something
we can pick up with
um when we spoke to the civil servants
and they made it very clear
that
that the ministers and the mps have been
disappointed by the lack of cultural
funds and funding goods overseas they've
been overwhelmed with
town-centric development and at latterly
infrastructure bids
therefore we wanted to be our best
opportunity for gaming's advance to look
at what cultural elements within the
district we could support with
significant capital investment
okay counselor channel uh thank you very
much madam chairman um i think it's
really good news within the report which
i was aware of anyway that we've moved
up to level one
um from level two because i see that as
a great benefit and i wondered if we
have any inclination of why that has
occurred i'm glad that government have
actually woken up and seen that that's
where malden should be
and then to say regarding um this we got
i mean i heard about the end i wouldn't
want jack ellen to be forgotten because
uh i'm sure he's ever grateful that
leander arrived because i'm very much
aware of he was trying to juggle a
multitude of issues to do with economic
development and jobs um sense of place
and everything else but of course
leander coming um we're really moving
forwards at greater pace and i think
it's now got a very good team working
together i think they work well together
and it's certainly delivering results
for the council
so regarding how many in these um
sort of funds and putting it together
leandra i know you're obviously
being the main piece there but how many
have you got supporting you really just
to know and it's going to be obviously
elements coming from across the council
but can we just perhaps have an
indication really of the support that's
going to be available in knocking this
all up together thank you
so we're working with the strategic
thing leads and various offices across
the council but also looking at with the
capacity funding to buy in consultancy
services in order to support us to bring
the bid up to the government's green
book standard and also to
as the
fundings are inherently
to support our investment plan for the
uk shared severity plans and we've got a
competitive quotation out of the
services to support us at the moment
council channel uh can i just come back
on i just make a point are you
mentioning consultants coming in i have
to save something on this
i think probably that's um a very good
plan and nothing against offers in the
past i'm very well over a bid where we
did a very good bid but perhaps had we
had a
consult i know this isn't on the same
level what we're talking about now but
had we had perhaps a consultant
assisting then we may have had the
success then that's nothing against
officers but sometimes
um the consultants know this speak that
you put into these various things so
thank you and i'm glad you're going to
get the support that you you need thank
you
okay thank you um
councillor swain i've got next thank you
and
yes um assume that we're basically
talking about
um
projects being put forward by
the council although i or
outside bodies as well
i certainly hope there are projects put
forward accountable um as far as this
increase in a priority of status
will be guess actually from looking at
the changes take place as it's probably
due to poor
connectivity and therefore anything that
improves connectivity and transport may
be
a candidate and there are one or two
other areas and the lack of cultural
projects as mentioned
the
um
there is a question the
key heritage idea was mentioned but um
there's also whether um
um should we say a project for
acquiring premises um
closer to the center
as i say indoor market plus galleries
and workshops or whatever like that for
community purposes might also be a
candidate
and
also with reference to the
infrastructure idea whether either these
funds support us actually buying this
site for a health center
rather than rely on putting it through
planning and relying upon some
development um the the overall question
chairman is how this is going to be
organized and how projects are going to
be
examined and sifted
um whether
the shortlist or any key main ideas will
come back to this
committee for consideration at an early
stage
the leveling up fund
the deadline is extremely tight so we
haven't in the middle of july to submit
that bid and as i mentioned it needs to
be up to the green book standard so
we're looking at existing priorities and
strategies which have been approved by
members in order to bring forward that
infrastructure bid in a timely manner
in a way that we can
show our best face to central government
with the uk sheriff's verity fund we do
have a slightly
longer time scale so up to the end of
august crucially we asked to wait for
further tech guidance for central
government which they've assured us will
be with us in the summer
and so we look forward to receiving that
to better understand the outcomes of
funds but we are in charge of developing
people working with a partnership group
we will act as a soundtrack
and a partnership with us to look at the
projects that we are looking to deliver
and we have spoken to colleagues and the
chair of walmart district for that group
as it contains the correct mix of
stakeholders for us to be able to work
with them collaboratively to deliver
projects that have the best
outcomes for residents and businesses at
the economy
thank you
okay i've got councillor durham nixon
councillor thompson council lag i'm
councillor civil and then council of
floopers so
yeah just a couple of points thank you
chairman of the team have done a
fantastic job leander and jack and
and co you know not only with this but
with all of the covid um funds that we
had but you know we have to bear in mind
that the leveling up fund is a new fund
that we you know four or five years ago
we couldn't have predicted the covid uh
the injection of money that we've had
from the government for copied recovery
etc
unfortunately four or five years ago
we were faced with a situation this
authority was faced with a situation
where if we didn't do anything we were
going to be looking at a million pounds
a year deficit
and within four years it was predicted
that all of our reserves were gone and
we would be effectively broke so
unfortunately the transformation
was
essential now i'm not saying everything
went absolutely to plan because it
didn't um and we probably
haven't ended up how we originally
envisaged it but unfortunately and as
you will recall mr holmes and councillor
fluker will recall we we had a a dire
financial situation of uh that that had
to be addressed um but you know and if
at that time we'd known that kobe was
going to come along and the government
was going to open its wallet and we were
going to have the new leveling up agenda
throwing money around then it we might
have done things a bit different but
hindsight is
is a wonderful thing but as i said you
know we were faced with a potential
million pounds a year
deficit unless we did something
and that's the reason that we embarked
on that thank you
thank you and councillor thompson
thank you and thank you to councillor
durham who's already said most of that
was going to say only much better
um yeah i was going to say the
transformation and the ldp those of us
who were here did the very best we could
with what we had
uh it's very easy to criticize
afterwards it's very easy for us who
were here and tried to manage it to
criticize afterwards it's certainly not
without its thought i'm incredibly
grateful that you know we've managed to
find a way of having people on the table
and you know
the extra staff where we've needed them
um you know nobody could have expected
coving when the transformation should
have been embedded in and corrected um
well everything pretty much went mad i'm
sure mr holmes could bear me out on that
so not only were we working up to full
capacity which was what the
transformation planned for
um unlike a normal business rather than
trying to manage with coded we had to
manage with covet on all the
accompanying issues and produce huge
amounts of extra work and extra output
on top of it you know managing grants
and so on so
yeah we're a little bit late to the
party with putting the transformation
right i'd love to have done it sooner
but as councillor durham said we were
basically being broke
and it it had to be done and we did
what we had to do at the time thank you
for the time absolutely yeah we had to
make that decision at the time on the
evidence that we had um right okay i've
got council again councillor sidle and
then councillor fluker yeah i'll talk
about the future rather than the past
because we can't change that can we um
the i think it's a really good report
thank you and i think that any sort of
funding you know if we have to invest 20
000 to be able to go for it is a very
sensible thing and that there is there
is one um
and members won't be surprised if
there's one little splinter that's
scratching at the back of my neck it's
on three point two one two mr how many
people are hurt on the key every year
chairman i don't have any accident
records here this evening but i can i
can inquire for him and uh
yeah thanks richard and i'm really sorry
to throw in the deep end but i don't
think it'll be very many because i i'm
starting to get very niggled about the
fact that the height key is a dangerous
place and i hope when we come through
the languages in here that would make it
safer
when i hope that when this comes through
and i support some work to be done down
there i'm not totally against it there
will be full stakeholder
participation and there will be people
listen to people will be consulted and
the people who actually run and operate
down there that brings in millions and
millions of pounds now
millions of pounds now have a say in the
future because if if we get some of the
things going that i think that might be
coming through i don't think we're going
to get the outcome that we really really
want so it's i will say i have said it
and i'm pleased it's levied on the table
but i think the report and the the
structure of the whole thing is really
really good so thank you
mr holmes sherman i think i understand
the context of the the question um in
terms of improvements uh and improving
safety it's about reducing the risk and
potential there is a conflict between
pedestrians and vehicle movements on the
key area itself so any plans that we're
looking at would help to reduce any
potential conflict and future risk
i just come back as a chartered member
of iosh um i feel justified in coming
back and this will be the last time
which i'll say that and obviously when
you look at risk appetite you need to
look at what the number of hazards and
reports are against the number of
footfall to get the practicability of
that so um if it's very very small then
i don't want to spend 50 60 70 100 000
i'd rather do the buildings up get them
out
and look at other things so that we can
keep it going so i understand where
you're coming from and i know you
understand where i'm coming from so
thank you for your comments yeah mr
holmes will look into it and um you know
we do have to be mindful about safety um
with the the pedestrians and the traffic
um right okay councillor sidle next uh
thank you chad uh yeah i understand the
reason behind the transformation of
course i do uh but what we need to and
and it and it enabled the council to
function effectively during that because
of the technology that we was introduced
however what we need to do now and and
i've said it over the last six months is
look at what we need to be as a council
now and in the future and that's the
crucial element we need to ensure we've
got the right resources the right people
and it's unfortunate that
not only are we having to do this bid
but we're also having to bid for a
consultant
so there's a there's a two-step complex
process behind actually getting this bid
in rather than it being able to be done
purely in in-house as it were
the other really good thing that you
know that eventually was set up last
year it took quite a long time uh
because there didn't seem to be complete
will
across the council chamber about this
although i remember councillor stamp and
myself being very very positive about it
but it didn't seem to have positive yeah
and that is the fact that we have
finally set up one molded and having set
up one molden you know we are now able
to use those resources in terms of these
bids and use those connectivity that
we're starting to create with one baldur
so that so
yeah there's a huge benefit that that
now is in place
thank you
councillor siddal okay councillor fluke
next yeah thank you chairman um
paragraph 3.2.5
um i was quite surprised to see this
because the south malden relief road
was supposed to be provided for by a
section 106 agreement
as members will know the the cost of the
infrastructure works
were agreed by essex county council
uh the developers all agreed to make
their necessary contributions
and then it was found in the same way as
david fisher way in um
southminster which is being delayed
whilst the council raises some more
money and when i say the council i mean
the highway authority
um
gemini i'd ask chairman that um
we one of the officers write to uh the
highways authority and ask them when
they are going to deliver this because
this is going to be critical not only
for the development but for the
other
uh developments which are now
confidential which are coming by coming
close by so i really would like to hear
from essex
uh highways authority the actual
highways authority um because i've i've
spoken to them several times and i've
spoken to the the member for highways
the cabinet member for highways and you
know their feeling is well they don't
have the money we've got to wait for
april then it's the following april so i
really would like to know when this is
going to be delivered jim thank you yeah
thank you councilwood um i think mr
holmes um could you help assist on this
one
oh sure sorry
mr dulce didn't spot you down there
sorry if you could assist
um yes
there's been a significant work
undertaken over the last
year
highways around the section 106 funding
for the the south mountain
relief road we did put the video
in the previous round of the leveling up
to try and accelerate the delivery
but great progress is being made um it's
working around the sectional assets
funding having the discussions with
the highways authority and looking to
bring forward the detailed design which
will be the first stage
we need a detailed design stage which is
going to be through section 106 to be
complete before we could attract any
further external function so that's
being progressed at the moment and to
try and drive the cost down close that a
gap that has existed
so we're working now with both the irs
authority and the nhs to try and align
the delivery times for the health
hardware and for the road to come
forward um i'm happy to share some
further information on that with
councillors
yeah i'm grateful chairman but i think
all members would like to hear that
update because clearly some you know
some seem to uh have had an update and
others haven't but you know i'm grateful
for the work that mr dodson's done but
you know
it's an essex highways matter you know
we should be working with essex highways
we appear to be taking the lead on this
so when you're talking about resources
we should make sure that we're actually
expanding our resources where we should
they are supposed to be delivering this
road but i'm sure mr dodson's got a good
uh handle on it so i'll i'll park it
there thank you yeah i i i say thank you
for the question um councillor fluke
it's something that we're all really
sort of interested in because it's been
rumbling on for years and years and
years and as part of the ldp the only
reason we approve these areas was
because of the flood alleviation fund
then lo and behold here we are again it
hasn't been delivered but um anyway if i
might go on to councillor chana's next
then council stand councillor swain
thank you very much madden chairman uh
just regarding some issues that come up
and council against me
sorry just regarding some of the points
that have come up um
council lagging referred to the high key
and the elements there and obviously the
report made reference to the central air
action plan
and
are you going to be relying or utilizing
perhaps in your considerations some of
the historic information because i
certainly am one of the members who sat
in a number of workshops with many
businesses and other organizations in
malden town council um hall
discussing actually the central air
action plan i know very much the high
key and the elements surrounding that
came into the equation i'm not going to
say any more about the transformation
program because i think that's being
done to death tonight regarding ron
malden the point i would make i'm a
supporter of one malden i have to say in
the early days it was the fact that it
wasn't enough information in the reports
that went to members and that all
changed and in fact i think the
information that members did eventually
see on that such as the terms of
reference enabled the meeting that we
held on the launch of one walden to go
very much more smoothly
regarding the point of the relief road
and mr dodson's now mentioning it as
councillor fluker's question if any
member is going to get any information
as a result of a question placed in this
committee madam german i felt quite
strongly that all members should receive
that same information some members of
the committee and now mr dodson had said
that the the production or delivery if
you like of the relief road is going to
be aligned with the malden hub then as a
member and you as well council miss
white who are appointed to the malden
operations um board we would like to
know very much when perhaps we might be
meeting so as members of this authority
we can make representation and give
views points on that delivery and have
an an idea of what is planned uh
regarding that so thank you very much
and perhaps mr dodson can give some
indications of when that body which
should be meeting um perhaps will
convene so councillor miss white and
myself have the opportunity to have the
member involvement thank you thank you
mr dawson
yes thank you um
discussion with the nhs
um regarding the target
as i said earlier
what we've also done is requested that
the molten operational group
is reinstated to enable members to to
engage in in that discussion but at the
moment a lot of the work that's been
undertaken certainly over the last six
months has been very
technical to get into the stage where we
can present
um what
might be possible how we can align those
those type scales but i certainly well
aware of the need to get that member
engagement back in place we will
continue to lobby and press the nhs
around doing that
um if i could also pick up while class
i'm speaking um there was quite a lot
there with what what counselor channel
said and i think
the record secular master plan which i
think is really important within the
this bid
you know as the answer said earlier that
the time scales are very tight
um the bid has to be levelling up in the
first week in july so it's really
important that we do draw on the central
area master plan and that work that is
already part of the lgp policy um as an
existing spd
um because then you know it can
demonstrate that that's been consulted
upon that there's a deliverability
around it if we could draw in that
government funding there's a real
legitimacy to delivering those programs
so definitely putting on that
and that's one of the reasons that we we
selected the hive key
around the
deliverability of those those projects
thanks yeah thank you mr dawson i've had
some really good questions tonight i
know it's gone on for a while but
they've all been really good and really
relevant and i would say i i'd like to
thank both you for the hard work that
you've done um on on this funding
um but i do very iterate what counselor
channel said that we really the members
really must be kept updated because this
is the first i've heard about the health
hub being discussed bringing it forward
and so we all members really need to be
um kept updated certainly on the working
group and going forward to all members
um councillor stamp
german i'll be madame chair i'll be
brief um councillor fluco raised that
very valid point at pg a at the last
committee meeting did you counsel fluker
about the relief road and you actually
asked for a member of essex county
council highways have you forgotten to
come to that actual meeting so is it
going to come to this committee or is it
going to go to pg a mr dodson may be
able to help us on that but i'm sure i
sat in a meeting with you and you and
councillor boyce was sitting over here i
was sitting over there and you raised
the very point so just for clarification
where is it the report going to go to
thank you mr dudson
i believe it was um to be an invite to
the messick's highways themselves to
cover rather than a report itself so the
representation was requested
they have been invited
and we will make sure that they're
invited to a future meeting and the
members receive that breach as requested
and generally i just say i mean you know
um um councillor stamps knowledge of
seating plans i think uh is first class
but yeah i mean look we've got a program
committee that is you know decided on
the course of action you know if they're
not coming to the next meeting of pg a
um then we need a short report to say
why they're not coming and and channel i
think it really would be nice also
perhaps to invite the cabinet member
along from highways as well
i think that's a break a
suggestion councillor fluker i i think
we should absolutely extend an
invitation um to to the uh chairman yeah
so um hang on i'll just i've just
okay answer down kevin
it isn't actually down to the cabinet
member for highways it's down to the
cabinet member for infrastructure
oh okay right well if we extended
an invitation to that member and i think
maybe then they'll see how interested we
are and how keen we are to take this
forward and i think that would be really
good
by the way oh thank you councillor
durham um right i've got councillor
chana and then i've got councillor swain
well actually that now you i was just i
was just thrusting my arm actually but
now you mentioned it
if it is going to pga then actually i
think a notification should go out to
all members because i think you might
find a full house coming into that
meeting absolutely i think that i
absolutely agree because everybody is
keen to see this progress i certainly am
um and and thank you um councillors
fluker and channel for bringing this up
right councillor swain
thank you
um notwithstanding everything has
recently been said about the malden
operational group and
south modern relief road and where the
highways are actually doing anything can
i
put the question asked for an answer to
the question i did for
initially
whether um purchase of land for a site
for a hub would be it
would qualify under either of the um
funding schemes that we've been talking
about
yeah i think it might be too late to put
it in now but i'll go for it is that
leander can you help assist with that
one
paul would you first come
yes thanks
um it would be outside of the time
scales but it's largely the
company you need to be those that have
planning permission or a clearly credit
i think it's too early in the
development
um for us to be able to secure something
like that for that project hence my
reference previously to central area
masterclass projects which are already
part of the existing ldp that gives us a
real strong basis around deliverability
and evidence that we can put together
the five cases that's required for a bit
of this scale at this level of detail
yes i i take uh
what
mr dawson has said
but the question was really whether in
principle
um uh such an idea would qualify if not
for this round and perhaps for the next
round
through you chairman it's it's something
that we could look at
but
there are various
streams of funding
that the nhs for example can tap into
and to agree part of the agreement
process is making sure that there's not
duplication of funding so it'd be quite
a complex process to look into but one
that we could look into
whether it was an opportunity to do that
should there be a
thank you
um right okay we've got two
recommendations on this little one is
that we note the opportunity presented
for investment in the district by the uk
shared prosperity fund and the leveling
up fund and the council's role in
securing the investment administration
and
good and no little four that the use of
any government allocated property
funding to develop the council's
applications to both funds be approved
goodbye
okay thank you members
okay moving on to agenda item 10 which
is the appointment of representatives on
outside bodies and working groups
i'm not sure who's presented to this but
i would agree to happy to agree with the
recommendations oh councillor stamp
please don't cite that's counselor jenna
oh
now i'm happy to agree the
recommendation i just have a question if
that's all right maddie chair um um
could i ask um cancer through you madam
chair what has happened with the
equality diversity inclusion officer
working group and if there is minutes
and notes from that working group
because i've not heard anything
and i'm just wondering how it how it's
actually progressing and i think cancer
siddal is the one to um you know is the
gentleman on that group so if he's
allowed to speak
can i answer my question
to speak
uh yes it has uh recently uh met and uh
it was about i think two weeks ago chris
so we at that particular point we
there was it was a review of where we
are in terms of equality on diversity
and within the council
as as part of that a matter was raised
around issues around the hearing loop
for example in reception and there
wasn't one so yeah that's now being
implemented and also looking at where
there's a hearing loop in the chamber as
well
and whether whether that could be
installed so it's looking at things like
that in terms of
the
uh
members or sort of the offices of the
council they've all gone through
training
in terms of it over the last six months
we are looking at how we had uh joshua
faulkner is looking at how he works with
communities in terms of equality
diversity inclusivity things around
dementia um as well and the actions that
we're looking at in terms of making the
high street a dementia friendly place so
there are lots of things i'm sure
that um the officers could put forward a
formal
review of where we are mr leslie
[Music]
yep
absolutely
there was actions listed out within that
uh edi strategy and part of that was
actually to uh review and check on
progress um that obviously a meeting uh
occurred to update there and provide the
information and that update will then
come to committee just to give all
members an update on what's happened in
progress against those action points
which were agreed
thank you um i've got councillor
channeling council stamps councillor
channel thank you very much that was
going to be my point so i'm welcoming
that to that there will be a report
because i think actually it was all set
up before december last year actually
and we haven't heard and here we are now
into may so i'd be very welcome can i
please ask as part of it bearing in mind
it is equality diversity inclusivity
bearing in mind that members and staff
do have disabilities
has there been any consultation or any
consideration of consultation with those
members that might actually have
valuable experiences or needs that
perhaps at the moment are unmet and
would that not be a useful exercise to
carry out should that not have been the
case
yeah absolutely as part of the
consideration seriously it's a good
suggestion we've obviously looked at
accessibility audit of the offices as
well to check that
that
can take place and we've
looked at that side of it for officers
uh public as well in terms of that and
that's the sort of thing that can be
picked up and welcome suggestions and
contacts from that for for future as
well
madam chairman there's hidden
disabilities i'm not necessarily talking
about the obvious and i just think it'd
be rather nice perhaps instead and i
don't mean this really in any way
perhaps those people on the working
group might not have the experiences
that some members and staff who may have
those disabilities do have and could
inform the process and make sure we are
truly
involving equality diversity and
inclusivity
[Music]
i entirely agree because many of memphis
members have hidden disabilities that
nobody knows about um and so we wouldn't
make them public but it's something that
needs to be included and staff so that
everybody has the same amount of um
support and right what council the
channeling counselor said you can come
back as councillor so
councillor stamp and then councillor
siddal and then councillor durham thank
you madam chair i was just going to say
thank you to councillor siddall for the
update i think it's important and i
actually agree with the recommendations
thank you
council
yeah obviously yeah i am the only member
rep but because we didn't want to
overload because there is only three
officers on the working group so we
wanted to have a balance in terms of
representation when it comes to
personal disabilities that's a very
sensitive subject
and yeah
i'm sure members probably don't want to
talk to another member about those
things
but there is an hr representative on
that working group so i think the best
route for those issues or any of those
concerns is through the hr rep
um you know in terms of the organization
and in terms of that process because it
is about keeping privacy and sensitivity
around those particular things but also
recognizing are we meeting everybody's
needs um
so
yeah to come and discuss it in a working
group probably not the most comfortable
place but using a channel through to it
yeah either through me as the member rep
but if someone doesn't feel comfortable
with that using the hr person who's on
that on the working group um would be
the right approach and it is important
that we all recognize the need for this
within the council um
and it yeah one of the things that
members really need to do is to show
their commitment to it because earlier
in the year when we had the training
we didn't get half of the members
turning up for it
yeah and that that to me is is quite
significant so yes it's really important
but members need to show their
commitment that they they agree with
this and believe in this
yeah and i think actually we it's
something we can take forward um with
the directors with that with a a route
for these uh inquiries to go through so
i shall certainly raise that after this
meeting um councillor darren
yeah just very quickly uh yeah i i
totally appreciate what councillor
chandler is saying and and again
councillor said there needs to be
uh
an avenue where the people can discuss
confidentially yes absolutely any issues
that they have yeah and um there is
actually a hearing loop in here but
other members might remember we had a
lot of trouble with it because people
with hearing aids in the northern room
and even downstairs could hear when the
private and confidential was coming
yeah so
it actually worked rather too well um on
occasion so thank you chad yeah um thank
you um right so now we've had the debate
um do we all agree the recommendation on
mass thank you oh councillor swain just
quickly i will indulge you
um the representation
yes
yes but it's been agreed now so yes
okay
um okay right um agenda item len 11 any
other items of business that the
chairman of the committee decides our
urgent if we please know there are none
so we'll move on quickly to agenda item
12 which exclusion of the public and
press to resolve that under section 184
of the local government act 1972 the
public be excluded from the meeting for
the following items of business on the
grounds that they involve the likely
disclosure of exempt information as
defined in paragraph 3 of part 1 of
schedule 128 of the act and that this
satisfies the public interest test
yeah probably yeah
you